en este vídeo vamos a tomar nuestro
motor que va a hacer nuestra rueda y que
era de nuestra secadora y vamos a ver
cómo incorporarla a nuestra estructura
aquí estoy marcando en donde se ubican
los lugares donde van los tornillos en
el anillo de la lámpara y que sirven
para conectar el anillo con la base
vamos a medir la distancia entre estas
marcas hay unos 9 centímetros entre
ellas y vamos a hacer una marca a la
mitad a unos 4.5 centímetros nos
aseguramos de que nuestra marca quede en
la medida correcta usando nuestra regla
en ambos lados es muy importante que
nuestra marca quede en el centro para
que nuestras ruedas se alineen cuando
las colocamos hacemos lo mismo del otro
lado nuevamente la distancia es de 9
centímetros por lo que la mitad está a
4.5 centímetros ahora llevamos esta
marca hacia abajo y vamos a usar la
parte interior de nuestro rollo de cinta
aislante para
el arco que necesitamos para el hueco de
nuestra rueda ahora vamos a medir la
altura que hay desde donde termina la
base del tornillo y es de 1.5
centímetros ahora transferimos esta
medida a la parte de afuera y será la
altura máxima del arco que vamos a
dibujar para nuestra rueda alineamos la
parte interior de la cinta con la marca
y usamos nuestro plumón para dibujar el
arco
una vez que dibujamos el arco podemos
comenzar a quitar el material que sobra
para que nuestros motores quepan en esta
estructura nos ponemos guantes de
seguridad y aquí uso un cúter aunque
quizás debe usar otra navaja especial
para escarbar o tallar como pueden ver
la punta se acaba de romper así que si
usan este tipo de navajas asegúrense de
usar lentes de seguridad ahorita estoy
quitando pedazos de material y es un
material suave y fácil de cortar así que
vayan cortando y quitando pequeños
pedazos de material
asegurarse de no ir más allá de la línea
que marcamos ya que si lo hacemos
nuestras ruedas no se van a alinear
aunque no pasa nada si nos pasamos un
poquito pero no va a lucir también así
que limpiamos bien la orilla de este
arco y hacemos lo mismo del otro lado
usando exactamente el mismo proceso
alineamos nuestro motor con el hueco y
vemos que encaja perfectamente debemos
asegurarnos de que el hueco sea del
tamaño adecuado para el motor
ver estos elementos de plástico que una
en la parte exterior de el motor con la
caja que lo rodea y que básicamente nos
protege de las aspas del ventilador
bueno vamos a tener que quitar algunos
de ellos para hacer que el ventilador
toque el suelo pues nuestro ventilador
será nuestra rueda y para que pueda
mover nuestro robot adelante y atrás
debemos quitar la parte de abajo de esta
capa protectora de plástico transparente
vamos a quitar uno abajo y tres arriba y
aquellos que no vamos a cortar los
marcamos con el plumón tomamos nuestras
pinzas de corte para cortar estas
secciones que queremos quitar así que
las quitamos
y ahora vamos a tomar nuestra segueta y
vamos a cortar la cubierta plástica
superior que rodea a las aspas y vamos a
asegurarnos de alinear las dos hojas
propulsoras de manera que cuando
cortemos la protección exterior no
cortemos las aspas del ventilador porque
éstas nos van a servir como ruedas aquí
aceleramos el vídeo para no aburrirlos
previamente corte el otro lado este lado
casi está listo terminamos de cortarlo
usando nuestras pinzas de corte vamos a
asegurarnos de que las aspas están
expuestas lo suficiente y vamos a
limpiar las orillas con nuestro cuter
para quitar las irregularidades de estas
y asegurarnos que todo está limpio
expuesto y listo para usarse
ahora podemos ver que el motor se mueve
libremente y está en contacto con el
suelo seguimos revisando que todo gire y
se mueva libremente en la parte de
arriba podemos ver que tenemos una marca
con plumón que dibujamos poniendo el
anillo encima del motor y ahora queremos
cortar en esta marca tomamos nuestra
segueta y comenzamos a cortar el
plástico en ángulo para acercarnos a
esta línea lo más que podamos está en un
ángulo de 20 grados y estamos cortando
hacia abajo a lo largo de esta línea que
dibujamos con el plumón lo que queremos
lograr es que esta protección de
plástico pueda rodear el anillo de la
lámpara cortar a través de este plástico
lleva bastante tiempo pero como lo
estamos haciendo a mano lo podemos
sostener así
ahora tomamos nuestras pinzas de corte
para cortar estas conexiones
y vamos a cortar lo que aún nos falta
quitar ya estamos bastante cerca de lo
que queremos para que calce
perfectamente tendremos que cortar estas
orillas con nuestras pinzas alicates
para que quede libre el borde que
queremos y ajuste bien en el anillo esto
requiere de bastante paciencia pero creo
que es mejor quitar los pedazos poco a
poco que quererlo quitar todos de una
sola vez y que nuestro borde no quede
bien
ahora lo probamos y vemos que el motor
queda perfectamente bien en el anillo
nuestro motor sigue teniendo protección
alrededor de las aspas solo quitamos un
poco más de material para que el ajuste
entre el motor y el anillo sea perfecto
tendremos que cortar estas orillas con
nuestras pinzas de corte incluso podrían
cortar toda la pieza con las pinzas de
corte en lugar de usar la segueta pero
pues yo pensé que sería más fácil usando
la volvemos a checar la conexión entre
el motor y el anillo inspeccionando la
muy de cerca pueden ver que encajan bien
pero seguimos verificando que no haya
puntos que eviten que gire bien el motor
y que todo quede donde queremos
algunos bordes abultados en el plástico
de cuando cortamos las uniones con
nuestras pinzas de corte así que lo
animamos para quitarlos y así el motor
no raspe al acrílico o el hexa el motor
necesita estar nivelado porque vamos a
fijarlo en su lugar y si el motor tiene
estos bultos pues no va a quedar bien
nivelado
ahora estamos haciendo cuatro pequeñas
marcas que están a ambos lados del motor
y las usaremos para pasar nuestras
cintas sujetadores o cinchos pasaremos
el cincho de un lado a otro y usaremos
una broca de un cuarto de pulgada o de
puntos seis centímetros es decir seis
milímetros vamos a quitar los tornillos
en nuestra estructura quitamos el exxon
le perforamos los agujeros que marcamos
para el motor lo que nos permitirá
insertar nuestros hinchas limpiamos los
bordes con nuestro cutter y nos
aseguramos que se alinean con nuestro
motor si lo hacen y los agujeros son lo
suficientemente anchos como para que
pasen nuestros cintos vamos a
asegurarnos de que el extremo abultado
de nuestros hincho quede hacia arriba
del examen para que el cincho apriete
con seguridad del motor y como el motor
tiene el plástico en dos niveles vamos a
poner un pequeño calce o pedazo extra de
plástico que nos ayudará a sostener el
motor
plano ahora ajustamos el cincho hasta
que quede bien pegado al motor y podemos
ver que el motor está bien asegurado
ahora vamos a tomar otros hincho y
haremos lo mismo en el otro lado aquí
estamos empujando hacia atrás el calce
para asegurarnos de que no se vaya a
caer el tc es un pedazo del examen con
el mismo grosor cortamos un pedazo de
1.3 centímetros cuadrados y lo colocamos
por debajo de esta parte del motor vamos
a poner otro shincho en este mismo motor
con el otro motor vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo
el extremo abultado del cinto debe
quedar por arriba del excel pasamos el 5
por abajo del motor y lo sacamos por
arriba asegurando lo y ajustando lo bien
esto nos permite no solo sujetar el
motor sino ajustarlo de ser necesario
para asegurarnos de que se alinea con el
eje imaginario que indica el lugar en
donde deben ir los motores
al terminar de ajustar los podemos usar
el destornillador para empujarlo hasta
el fondo pero por ahora vamos a dejar
largos los cinchos por si más adelante
tenemos que reajustarnos y es así como
montamos los motores de vichy bot el
otro motor lo colocamos exactamente
igual